tron sommes en direct avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes cofondateur de la
revue le monde moderne bonsoir alexis
poulain merci d'être avec nous on l'a vu
à la russie qu'il parle d' hypocrisie
notamment au sujet d'emmanuel micron
fait la comparaison avec le soutien et
la gestion au gilet jaune est ce que
c'est une comparaison qui vous paraît
justifiée oui dans le cadre de la
violence qui a été démontré par l'état
français pour réprimer les
manifestations des gilets jaunes il ya
eu beaucoup de blessés il ya eu des
morts également on se rappelle de cette
vieille dame à marseille qui ne faisait
rien la fenêtre de son appartement
donc effectivement il ya quelque chose
de l'ordre de l'hypocrisie puisque la
l'europe n'avait pas réagi alors si le
conseil de repos quelques institutions
avaient quand même dit que la doctrine
de matières de lord en france avec
quelques problèmes de violence et
notamment l'utilisation des lbc et entre
autres mais là clairement c'est encore
une fois mails mâcon dans un exercice
d'ingérence dans lesquelles il excelle
il est liban il ya quelques jours
maintenant la biélorussie et l'europe a
beau jeu de faire finalement l'unité
pour dire et condamné un pays tiers qui
n'est pas dans l'union européenne c'est
évidemment plus facile puis ça permet de
aussi de masquer et bien les différences
de politiques étrangères au sein des
membres de l'union européenne parce que
on parle de biélorussie mais il y à ce
qui se passe aussi avec la turquie en
itéra n'est hélas les membres de l'otan
ne savent pas comment réagir par rapport
à la position française
l'allemagne est totalement en désaccord
avec la façon de kaimana bacon de gérer
cette crise avec la turquie
donc c'est une façon facile en fait de
trouver un mise en scène de l'unité
européenne pour condamner un président
russe qui vient de le dire était prêt à
organiser de nouvelles élections et un
référendum
emmanuel macron n'a jamais parlé de
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale de
référendum ou bien d'aller à aller coûte
des gilet jaune puisqu'il organisait son
grand débat qui a coûté plusieurs
millions d'euros d'argent du
contribuable et c'était lui qui parlait
seul pendant des heures au gilet jaune
plutôt que d'organiser des débats
citoyens
les cahiers de doléances qui ont été
rédigées par les différents gilet jaune
et bien ils dorment maintenant à la
bibliothèque nationale de france
ils n'ont pas été pris en compte non
plus donc bel exercice démocratique
qu'on peut saluer du côté français
alexis aux poulains que cherche selon
vous emmanuel macron justement à faire
entre guillemets de l'ingérence on a vu
qu'il a été très critiqué sur le dossier
libanais maintenant il se froisse avec
la russie avec laquelle il cherche
pourtant entretenir de bons rapports il
ya que des coups à prendre dans cette
affaire n'ont alors je crois que
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est
clairement entré en campagne que ce soit
sur ce qu'il a fait au liban ce qu'il a
fait en it et rannée avec la turquie
maintenant la biélorussie il parle
davantage à son électorat pro-européen
ici en france pour dire qu'il est
effectivement ce leader européen qu'il
n'a pas réussi à être puisque angela
merkel n'a pas laissé la place donc
c'est une façon de se mettre en scène
dans cette campagne pour 2022 qui a
commencé avec le gouvernement castex
gouvernement pléthorique qui va
permettre et bien de se mettre en scène
sur tous les fronts et lui maintenant
pas prendre de la hauteur va être ce
président international qui va
gesticuler de manière mondiale pour dire
que la france est leader qui les leaders
qui les lie des européens leaders de
l'europe libre contre les pays dits
démocratiques autoritaire etc
c'est pour moi je pense une façon
davantage de parler à son électorat en
france de se mettre en scène en france
pour remonter dans les sondages
et pour reprendre une stature
présidentielle qu'il a largement perdu
ces derniers mois quel est l'intérêt de
la france mais aussi de l'union
européenne dans son ensemble à ce que la
contestation se durcissent en
biélorussie elle intéresse c'est
d'affaiblir kenshin cookie est un
président depuis des années qui
apportait une certaine stabilité à la
ville aussi ça permet aussi de changer
je ne sais pas ce qui sera promis avec
les réseaux de la nouvelle opposition
qui est en exil mais qui se dit prête à
gérer le pays la femme de l'opposant qui
est maintenant presque prête à apprendre
le la fronde et les urnes c'est une
façon et bien de changer les cartes dans
cette région et de jouer là où l'europe
a arrêté son expansion territoriale avec
l'élargissement européen est bien de
faire tomber façon théorie des dominos
des pays anciennement amis
de la russie ou dans leurs beats de la
russie pendant ces dernières années donc
c'est une façon facile de continuer
l'élargissement européen de continuer ce
jeu là sachant que in fine et il y aura
une frontière avec la turquie ni
frontière avec la russie mais tous ses
pays limitrophes que ce soit les pays
baltes que ce soit maintenant la
biélorussie et bien il ya une volonté là
de faire ce que ce qu on accuse souvent
d'ailleurs les russes de faire en france
des campagnes d'information de
désinformation et bien l'europe n'est
pas en reste il y avait radio free
europe il ya l'otan aussi qu'il ya une
unité spéciale pour la l'information la
guierle il faut voir la guerre de
l'information donc c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
alors avec un bémol la biélorussie et on
parle quand même de milliers de dizaines
de milliers de centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues on voit les
images on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
derrière ça un vrai mouvement populaire
nous voulons une vraie colère contre ces
élections qui visiblement n'ont pas
reflété le vote des biélorusses
et puis il ya cette grève générale aussi
qui montre l'unité de la classe
prolétarienne qui est capable de mettre
le pays à l'arrêt et de faire changer
bien le président merci alexis paulin
pour votre analyse merci à vous